AT THOSE POLICE OFFICERS.
THIS OUGHT TO GET
THEIR BLOOD BOILING.
NOW, THE IDEA OF COMMITTING
AN ACT AGAINST THE POLICE
IS ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING.
[gunshot]
OOH!
[all screaming]
- ALL RIGHT, ANYBODY MOVE
AND THIS COP DIES!
- NO!
- LET'S GO.
- ELIZA, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
GET IN THE CAR.
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- GET IN THE CAR!
- WHAT HAPPENED?
- WHERE ARE WE TAKING THIS MAN?
- WE'RE KIDNAPPING THIS GUY!
- NO!
I WAS JUST GONNA THROW A BRICK!
[sirens approaching]
- GET IN THERE!
- ALL RIGHT.
- GET IN THE CAR!
- OKAY.
- I SWEAR TO [bleep] GOD,
I WANT TO KILL YOU!
I WOULD LOVE TO KILL YOU!
GET IN, GET IN!
- OH, GOD.
WHAT DO I DO WITH THE BRICK?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THE BRICK--OH!
- GO!
DRIVE! DRIVE!
- WE HAD A PLAN!
WE HAD A REALLY GOOD PLAN!
- NOBODY'S GONNA CHASE US IF YOU
THROW A BRICK THROUGH A WINDOW.
- OH, GOD.
DON'T SHOOT US!
OH, GOD, OH, GOD, OH, GOD.
- STOP OR I'LL SHOOT!
- SO FAR, BEING ON THE RUN IS
A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE.
DON'T DO IT!
THIS IS HORRIBLE.
ALL RIGHT, WHAT ARE WE DOING?
ALTHOUGH I WAS
AT FIRST CONCERNED
WITH HER ZEALOUSNESS...
SWITCHING CARS.
ELIZA'S HELP IN EXECUTING THIS
REVIEW WAS PROVING INVALUABLE.
HEY, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- SETTING THIS CAR ON FIRE!
- THAT'S JUST SELTZER WATER.
HEY, HEY, HEY!
- THEN HELP ME...
- WAIT, WAIT, WAIT!
HE'S RUNNING AWAY!
- DESTROY THE EVIDENCE.
- WHERE DID YOU GO?
HEY!
WHERE DID YOU GO?
I DON'T KNOW.
DID YOU SEE WHERE HE WENT?
HEY, HEY, HEY!
- WHERE IS HE?
- HE'S HERE, HE'S HERE.
HE'S HERE. HEY, STOP IT!
- [shouting]
- GET BACK HERE!
- I SWEAR TO GOD,
I WILL KILL YOU.
- HEY, STOP IT!
- I SWEAR TO GOD, I'LL KILL YOU!
- STOP, STOP, JUST STOP.
CAN YOU PUT THE GUN DOWN PLEASE?
- OKAY, YOU THINK THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE KIDNAPPED
A COP BEFORE?
- OKAY, NOPE--WHO ARE YOU?
- I'M MRS. FORREST MACNEIL!
NOW GET IN THE CAR!
[bleep] AMATEURS!
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S JUST GO.
[engine revs]
YOU'RE IN NEUTRAL.
- OKAY.
- WHAT ARE YOU GUYS,
SENDING THIS TAPE TO THE POLICE
AND ASKING FOR A RANSOM?
- WHAT?
WE DON'T WANT MONEY.
WE JUST WANT TO SEE WHAT
IT FEELS LIKE
TO BE ON THE RUN FROM THE COPS.
- LIKE A BONNIE AND CLYDE
KIND OF THING?
- YOU THINK THIS IS A MOVIE?
THIS IS REAL LIFE.
- BONNIE AND CLYDE WERE
REAL PEOPLE, ACTUALLY.
- YES, BUT IT'S A MOVIE FIRST.
- NO, IT WAS REAL PEOPLE FIRST.
- SHUT UP!
- FEELINGS OF INTENSE FEAR
AND PARANOIA
SEEMED TO BE CLOUDING
OUR JUDGMENT.
[water running]
- OKAY.
- [sighs]
- OKAY, GREAT.
NOW CHANGE CLOTHES.
- I--WHY--I-I DO NOT UNDERSTAND
ANY OF THIS,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
- SWEETIE,
THE COPS ARE GONNA BE LOOKING
FOR A GUY
THAT LOOKS LIKE IGOR DID
THIS MORNING.
- RIGHT.
IGOR?
- THAT'S HIS NAME.
- OKAY.
- HELLO.
- AND PUT THE MOUSTACHE ON.
I'LL SEE YOU OUTSIDE.